in this video we'll be discussing goodie
bag 7 on crystalline defects
the objectives are to visualize zero
dimensional one-dimensional and
two-dimensional defects and crystalline
materials
you'll need a double-sided strip of
adhesive two plexiglas panels and 500 1
16 inch metal beads
first pull off the protective film on
the top of your acrylic sheet
take four pieces of double sided tape
and put one piece on each of the edges
of the acrylic sheet
then carefully put your balls in the
middle of the
square made by the four pieces of tape
finally
remove the film on the top of the other
acrylic sheet and put it on top
when you're finished you should have a
completed defect modeling kit
now that you've built your model let's
use it to visualize how material
processing
impacts the number of defects visible in
a crystal when looking at our original
crystal you can see several defects
these are a vacancy line defect and
grain boundary defect
material processing can lead to both
increases and decreases in the number of
defects in the material
a process that leads to an increase in
number of defects is extrusion or
rolling because when we extrude or roll
a material
we force the atoms to go into certain
places and those aren't necessarily the
most energetically favorable states
let's look at our model to understand
how material processing leads to an
increased number of defects
when we shape the model we're able to
add defects to the system
as you can see now our model has an
increased number of vacancies line
defects and grain boundary defects
other material processing methods allow
for a decrease in the number of
vacancies
one possibility for this is annealing
when we anneal we heat the material up
and then we cool it slowly and allow the
atoms to move back to their more
favorable states
to illustrate annealing let's tap gently
on the side of our model
as you can see the number of defects in
our material has been substantially
reduced
in this goody bag we were able to
visualize some of the defects
seen in many crystals and we were also
able to see how processing conditions
impact the number of defects in a
crystal